(ambient music)
- [Voiceover] This is Amali.
She's an addax.
She's also a new mom.
Her calf Adeline is just three weeks old
and she's very important because the addax
is a critically endangered species.
The addax is a native of the
Sahara Desert, and once roamed
over vast areas of north Africa.
They're also known as
the screw horn antelope.
It's easy to see why.
They're extremely well
adapted to life in the desert.
Their white coats reflect
the scorching sun,
and their splayed hooves
are perfectly tailored
for traversing desert sands.
The addax can also survive
extremely long periods
without water.
But these adaptations are
no help against humans.
The addax has been hunted
nearly into oblivion.
Estimates put their population
at less than 200 individuals
in just a few pockets of the Sahara.
Luckily, reintroduction
efforts and captive breeding
programs like the one that
produced little Adaline
are helping the survival of this species
that has all but disappeared
from the face of the Earth.
This is the addax.